Americans aren't timid folks they are
people of action let's show you Jim
Jordan himself you you decide if this
sounds like clear and present danger
kind of stuff my favorite scripture
verse is 2 Timothy
4:7 Paul's the old guy giving advice to
the young guy Timothy and he says fight
the good fight finish the course keep
the faith and I tell folks I love that
verse because of the action in it
because of the word Americans aren't
timid folks they are people of action
and the words in that verse fight finish
keep I think fit the American
Spirit Americans expect their government
to fight for them they expect us to
finish our work and they expect us to
keep Faith with the principles and
values that made us the greatest nation
ever made us the nation that could go
from the right Brothers to Neil
Armstrong that's what we have to keep in
mind and that's the kind of attitude I
think we got to have the quickest way to
get all this working is to get a speaker
elected that's what what I hope we can
do
today I'll take your questions well it
did not happen he will not be the
speaker and it's like if you look at the
guy like do you think he's in it for the
show does it look like he's in it for
the show right like he doesn't even wear
a jacket like he's there to work he
usually has a sleeves rolled up that's
like a running joke with him he's there
to work he he would have been an
excellent speaker it's a damn shame it
didn't happen clear and present danger
maybe a clear and present danger to the
Socialist ideas of the Democrats of 2023
but certainly not to the nation uh but a
little bit from the daily wire on how
the whole thing fell apart uh after
representative Jim Jordan from Ohio
failed to get enough support to win the
speakership in three house floor votes
Republicans have elected to move on GOP
lawmakers voted to drop Jordan as their
nominee in a new secret ballot in a
republican conference meeting on Friday
the tally reported it was 86 to 112 a
new candidate forum is expected to take
place on Monday we need to come together
and figure out who our speaker going to
be I'm going to work as hard as I can to
help that individual so we can go help
the American people Jordan told
reporters after the secret B ballot so
look he's he's taken it in stride I
think he would have made a great speaker
it sounds like Byron Donalds who's from
Southwest Florida here is throwing his
hat in the ring we'll see what
happens